now the latest figures from Saturday
showed that a further 259 people in the
UK died after testing positive for
coronavirus the total now are over a
thousand feels like the curb that we
want as flattened continues to steepen
just how concerned is the government
well naturally we are very concerned and
our thoughts and prayers are with the
families of all those who've lost loved
ones in the last few days and today's
figures remind us how important it is to
maintain the social distancing rules
that the government have announced it's
absolutely critical that all of us stay
at home that we limit our trips away
from home to just one a day for exercise
we limit the amount that we shop if we
do that we can all play our part in
helping the NHS it's hard of course to
know how long this is going to go on for
but what's the government's working
assumption for when the peak is likely
to be well we're doing everything we can
at the moment to try to protect the NHS
by limiting the spread of the virus and
of course there are different models as
as you will know produced by academics
but we follow the best scientific advice
and that advice is for all of us if we
possibly can to maintain those social
distancing rules because if we do so
then we can flatten the curve we can
delay the onset of the of the peak and
then we can make sure that our NHS which
is becoming more resilient by the day is
better equipped to cope I can understand
you know you're not wanting to commit to
exactly when you think the peak is going
to be but it does feel like we're
wrestling we're that you acknowledge
some wildly different projections and
imperial for example one Imperial study
estimating only 5700 people could lose
their lives different papers said that
without social distancing it could be
260,000 yesterday the medical director
of the NHS saying that it would be a
good result for the United Kingdom if
the death toll was kept below 20,000 I
mean can you just tell us a bit about
what the reality is and what the
assumptions are that the government is
working - yes
the first thing to say is that that
every death is a tragedy for those
involved and we want to absolutely
minimize the the number of people who
died and we want to make sure that the
NHS is in the strongest possible
position to deal with the the enormous
public health challenge that we all face
on Friday I mentioned at the press
conference that the rate of infection
was doubling between three to four days
now that was obviously a reflection of
the latest figures as a result of the
social distancing measures that the
government has implemented we hope we
hope that we can reduce the rate of
infection but at this stage we just need
to make sure that everyone observes
those rules because again in a
challenging situation like this all of
us have our part to play and the way in
which everyone watching can play their
part is as as so many as the
overwhelming majority of people have
done is to follow rigidly the rules that
have been outside London the Prime
Minister and today has written to every
household it's a pretty bleak message in
some ways saying that things will get
worse before they get better
urging people to follow the rules as
you've been laying out this morning and
he also said he won't hesitate to go
further if necessary what further levers
could government pull well we want to do
everything we can both to reduce the
spread of the disease but also to
support to the NHS and it's always the
case that government stands ready if
necessary to do what it takes in order
to reduce the spread of infection at the
moment all the evidence is that people
are observing the rules if you look at
the number of people on public transport
that has fallen but if you look at
footfall in supermarkets and other
stores that has fallen as well all the
evidence is that people in a public
spirited generous fashion are displaying
sort of solidarity with the NHS and with
other frontline workers that we would
want to see but of course we keep things
under review in order to ensure that if
there are further steps they can be
implemented but what we have sought to
do is to make sure that we implement the
right steps at the right
time following appropriate scientific
advice the question was about what the
further levers could be and so what are
the further options that you're talking
about that the Prime Minister's talking
about I mean people really want straight
answers yes and I think we can take
further steps but it's important that
what am I thinking about something as
serious as this when we want to make
sure that we have the right steps in
place that were influencing people's
behavior in the right way that we are
keeping people safe that we don't
preempt discussion of what other steps
may be required but the Prime Minister
the whole government we follow the
advice that comes from our scientific
advisors from our medical advisers and
if there are appropriate steps that they
recommend that we take then we will take
them but it doesn't help those advisors
it doesn't help our preparations if we
preempt them before we need to at the
same time you're asking people to make
extraordinary changes to their lives
people are worried when they looking at
the figures that come out on a daily
basis showing the death toll ticking up
you won't tell us what the scientific
advice is what the working assumptions
are you won't tell us what the further
steps are that the government is
prepared to take
is there any direction that you can give
us on how long the lockdown for example
could last well at the moment it is the
case that as you say people are making
enormous sacrifices they are showing the
their sort of public spiritedness the
selflessness that is inspiring and the
best advice at the moment is for people
to observe the current guidelines and we
hope that that can flatten the curve
certainly all the evidence is that
people by observing those guidelines are
contributing to reducing the spread of
infection but it's also important to say
that the the scientific models are out
there people have had a chance to look
and to examine them the receive range as
people will know of potential outcomes
but those outcomes are not predetermined
influence those outcomes and if all of
us practice safe social distancing if
all of us stay at home then the number
of people who are being infected reduces
the resilience of the NH
can grow the NHS can become better
equipped to deal with this situation
the question was about how long the
lockdown could last for I'm still not
really that clear and professor Neil
Ferguson of Imperial one of the advisors
of course the government's following it
very closely
has said that he expects a lockdown to
last until early June is that a fair
expectation well as I say there are
different projections as to how long the
lockdown might last but it's not the
case that the the length of the lockdown
is something that is absolutely fixed it
depends on all of our behavior we can if
we follow the guidelines we can deal
more effectively with the spread of the
disease the models of projections and of
course we adjust our action on the basis
of behavior on the basis of data on the
basis of facts on the basis of science
but people should as the Prime
Minister's letter today
absolutely underlines and recognize that
the situation will get worse before it
gets better and that is why it is so
important that all of us play our part
it's also why it's so inspiring that
those leading the NHS have been able to
increase capacity increase the number of
beds available and ensure that we can be
in a better position to deal with the
increased level of infection and indeed
the increased level of mortality that is
coming talking about the NHS in
particular the government announced this
week that they're going to be rolling
out testing for the NHS workers who of
course really are on the front line on
the fight against this virus so when is
it going to happen and why has it taken
so long for the government to get to
this point well we have been increasing
the number of tests and I can confirm
today that the number of tests being
carried out has hit ten thousands now we
wanted to increase that ten thousand a
day we want to increase that to twenty
five thousand a day and just last week
the Prime Minister just Friday the Prime
Minister authorized a new programme of
testing so working with research
institutes and also
with companies like boots we're now in a
position to be able to test more boots
have opened drive-in Testing centers
were increasing a number of people being
tested all the time and of course it's
NHS and social care front line workers
who are first in line for those new
tests a full rollout then for all Health
social care another frontline workers as
you described it it's the ambition we
want to make sure that we can test test
and test again because of course if we
are able to test not only do we have a
better picture of the spread of
infection it's also the case that people
who at the moment our self isolating
because members of their family have
symptoms if we can test and we know that
they are negative then we can get them
to join the frontline and of course it
also critically protects the health of
people at the frontline we're working so
incredibly hard at the moment and whom
it is all our duty to support so what's
the timeframe then when will all NHS
workers all social care workers get
tested
well we've increased as I say the number
of tests to 10,000 a day we're going to
move to get that up to 25,000 a day and
we're doing all that we can to increase
and to accelerate that and I hope that
we will be able to to test as many
frontline workers at the earliest
possible stage we've been working as I
say with scientists with you know the
big players in providing medical
supplies and drugs like boots and others
in order to increase the number of tests
that we have and the UK has been one of
those countries which has been testing
proportionately a large section of its
population and some other countries but
there is more to do much more to do so
it doesn't sound like you can tell me
when the full rollout will be and many
will be wondering why it has taken so
long and two weeks ago today the chair
of the British Medical Association dr.
John Magpul was on this program saying
about how important it was to get
testing for NHS staff I can't emphasize
how serious the problem is we don't have
the luxury of time anymore why is it
that two weeks on you still can't tell
us when
NHS staff are going to get tested what
we are increasing the number of tests
and that's why so much effort and energy
has been directed by scientists and by
others in order to increase the number
of tests that take place as I say 10,000
people being tested today that is a
significant increase over where we were
last week and that number is going to be
increasing all the time the other part
of the fight on the NHS of course is the
number of ventilators the number of
intensive care beds and I know that the
government's been trying to kind of ramp
up the availability of both of those
things and you started I think from a
position of having 5,000 ventilators so
how many ventilators and how many
intensive care beds are now available
well we have available to the NHS now
just over 8,000 ventilators that's
because we've repurposed some of the
intensive care capacity that we have in
the NHS it's also the case that Simon
Stephens the chief executive of the NHS
has done deal with the private sector in
order to increase ventilator capacity
available to the NHS and we are going to
get another 8,000 or so ventilators
including summer which have been sourced
from abroad which are coming here from
other countries and of course we're
increasing our capacity to manufacture
ventilators in the UK as you'll be aware
we've done a deal with Tyson which means
that provided all the appropriate tests
are passed we can have and an additional
10,000 ventilators from that source
alone and there are other companies from
McLaren to rolls-royce and others who
are changing the way in which they they
manufacture in order to join in the
national effort to increase the
ventilator capacity available when it
comes to beds Simon Stephens again the
chief executive of the NHS outlined on
Friday that as a result of cancelling
the non-essential work in the NHS and
also as a result of the decision to open
a new hospital in East London NHS
Nightingale we've managed to release the
equivalent of 50 hospitals worth of new
beds to deal with
at 19 patients okay now the Prime
Minister and the health secretary both
tested positive for coronavirus this
week the chief medical officer is also
self isolating with symptoms of the
virus so there can be people who are
genuinely very worried about what this
means for the UK's response to kovat 19
so who is currently in charge and with
the Prime Minister's condition worsens
who will take over well the Prime
Minister is in charge on Friday morning
he chaired the the meeting that brings
all the effort of governments together
with ministers officials scientists and
doctors and he did so from his study in
Downing Street using modern technology
we had a video conference and the Prime
Minister was in charge he was the person
who was driving forward our efforts on
testing making sure that we increased
the number of tests available he was the
person who was interrogating Lee the
forward supply of ventilators in order
to make sure that we had the capacity
required he was the person who was
overseeing our support for frontline
workers in other areas in food
production and so on in order to make
sure that the life of the nation can
continue so he is very firmly in charge
and later this afternoon the Primus will
also be hosting another meeting by
videoconference with the relevant
ministers and officials if the Prime
Minister's condition worsens it's a
really straight question
well the Prime Minister is in charge at
the moment and anything if his condition
worsens I was just answering the
question the designated deputy to the
Prime Minister is the first secretary of
state dominic Rob thank you and then
just finally and to end on slightly more
positive note M nazan enziguri Ratcliffe
said to be considered for clemency in
Iran are you optimistic that she may be
able to come home I pray she comes
thank you very much for being on the
program let's duel Thank You Sophie
thank you